anyway here with reaction house
oversight committee chair James Comer
and house Judiciary Committee chairman
Jim Jordan
great to have you both
um
Pirates and Jordan let me start with you
all right so first we have I thought we
had whistleblower protection laws in
this country and I also thought that
that Democrats love to even hear say
whistleblowers uh but they only
apparently like whistleblowers uh if
they're going after Donald Trump uh we
now have allegations by both FBI
whistleblowers and IRS whistleblowers
that they're not being protected by the
laws in this country and that the
retaliation has taken place what can you
tell us about it no they're trying to
cross them and you're exactly right son
it was an anonymous whistleblower who
was the behind the whole impeachment of
President Trump a few years ago so
they're trying to crush these guys
because they're coming forward and not
only telling us about the double
standard in the attack on President
Trump but the attack on we the people
that's the scariest part of all but if
you step back and think about this
double standard for a second Sean think
about this seven years ago it was Jim
Comey Andrew McCabe and Peter strzok who
went after president Trump and his
campaign with no probable cause no
predicate no web evidence whatsoever Mr
Durham told us that this past week today
it's Alvin Bragg Bonnie Willis in
Georgia and of course now it looks like
Jack Smith here in Washington going
after president Trump and my guess is
they don't have any real probable cause
real PR real predicate or real evidence
to do that it just shows the double
standard and if you come forward and
talk about this stuff that's when they
come after you that's when they try to
crush you we saw that from those
whistleblowers last week in the hearing
all right so Jim Jordan's Committee just
to get everybody straight is looking
into whether the FBI is politicized and
the doj weaponized uh Jim Comer your
house oversight committee is looking
into the Biden family or the Biden
family Syndicate one of the things that
you were told uh is that there is a 1023
form and on this form it would be
evidence of what resulted in then Vice
President Joe Biden committing or
performing certain acts in exchange for
money for him and his family the FBI has
steadfastly refused to hand over that
document Now Kevin McCarthy after a
conversation with director Ray said that
it seemed like that would be forthcoming
and now I'm reading today again that
it's not forthcoming
yeah no I'm not as optimistic about
getting that from the director as
Speaker McCarthy I appreciate speaker
McCarthy he's sticking with me on this
but uh we've had two meetings with
surrogates from the FBI both meetings
were honestly very patronizing they were
talking about uh the need for us to
trust them and for us to not worry about
it the reason we're concerned about this
allegation is that it's consistent with
a pattern that we've seen in several
other countries where then Vice
President Biden would fly into a country
during the last year the Obama
Administration meet with government
officials and then Weeks Later members
of his family would receive through
shell companies direct payments from
foreign Nationals this uh informant
alleged this was taking place three
years before anyone knew about these
shell companies or anyone knew that
members of the Biden family were getting
money while Joe Biden was vice president
so that's why this is of the utmost
importance to us the FBI won't even
confir firm that this 1023 exists much
less tell us what exactly they did to
investigate the validity of the claim
let's talk about the latest in your
investigation uh Jim Jordan and and very
specifically we know that in 2016 that
the FBI uh we according to the Durham
report gave favorable treatment to
Hillary Clinton uh we also know that
operation Crossfire hurricane never
should have been opened we also know
that they used an unverifiable and false
uh dossier a dirty Russian dossier that
Hillary Clinton paid for
and they put their cinder blocks on the
scale of a presidential election but we
also know that it happened in 2020 in
the form of the FBI even though they had
Hunter Biden's laptop they authenticated
it according to John Solomon in the
spring of 2020 but they had in the
months leading up to the 2020 election
weekly meetings with big tech companies
warning them that they may be victims of
disinformation campaigns and it may be
about Joe and Hunter Biden now is that
the FBI putting their cinder blocks
again on the scale of an election and
can you add the CIA down to that list
yeah but it's not just the 2016 and 2020
election in between that and 2018 it was
the Mueller investigation and then this
past election in 2022 they raid
president Trump's home 91 days before
that midterm election but they didn't do
the same to Joe Biden even though they
knew he had classified document problems
they waited until after the election and
then of course here we are heading into
2024 and they're already doing the same
thing Alvin Bragg indicted president
Trump in New York using federal tax
dollars with no real issue there
whatsoever it's ridiculous what they did
Bonnie Willis is looking to do it in
Georgia the same darn thing and of
course Jack Smith has reported the Wall
Street Journal maybe as a special
counsel may be indicting president Trump
on the classified document issue Joe
Biden had classified documents four
different locations but they're going to
indict president Trump this is why this
this just this drives Americans crazy
and well it should and it's why what
Kevin McCarthy speaker McCarthy and
we're doing as Republicans to show how
these agencies have been turned on we
the people I think is so darn important
Congressman Comer will we ever get the
exact figure how much money the Biden
family did in business with hostile
regimes like Russia and China and
Ukraine and Kazakhstan and a dozen other
countries are we ever going to learn how
much money they made uh are we ever
going to discover what Joe Biden knew
when he knew it we know he lied to the
country when he said he never had a
discussion with his son about his
foreign business dealings when we get to
the bottom of this and do you believe at
the end of the day that access was sold
by then Vice President Joe Biden
I believe something of value was given
to these foreign countries these
adversaries are ours or they wouldn't
have sent so much money to the various
different members of the Biden family I
mean anyone that has any sense of
objectivity would recognize the fact
that it's not normal behavior for
relatives of a sitting vice president to
receive wires through phony companies
from foreign Nationals all over the
planet so I believe that we will get to
the bottom of it we've already uncovered
all these shell companies we've
uncovered various different bank
accounts we discovered that nine
different Biden families members
received payments this was information
that was never known before we began our
investigation just about three and a
half months ago so we're continuing to
follow the money Trail right now we're
hoping that we can get a little
information from the FBI because this is
an important part of our investigation
this is a link that will would directly
tie Joe Biden into this corruption so
hopefully the FBI will do the right
thing and we're going to continue to
press forward to get that information
all right Congressman James culmer
Thomas and Jim Jordan it's important
work for you both involved in you're
working in Tandem and we look forward to
the the results of the investigations
both of them thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else